well let's let's get serious about
what's going on the world though you
talk about all these very scary things
let's talk about the source of their
power
the large hadron collider inverse
reports the large hadron collider
restarts next week here's what it's
hunting for also right now
by the way also right there yes it is
i got i want to point something out i am
kidding i think it's going to be fun
that they restart this but there's a lot
of jokey
silly theories about they're not silly
all right all right but hold on you're
gonna love this one well you know geneva
that really is like the global head oh
for sure people think it's the u.n but
like geneva really is
like that's that's the main engine of
the united states okay
let's end the development
let's first say this yeah the large
hadron collider in geneva is restarting
next week a lot of people think weird
stuff is going on we have this story
from august 18th 2016. humans from this
is from the independent you can see
their little pride symbol next in their
logo even though it's maga month what
are they doing human sacrifice staged at
cern home of the god particle cern says
the ritual could undermine the actual
science that goes on at the organization
now here now they say a human sacrifice
has been staged in the grounds of the
european organization for nuclear
research the home of god particle a
video circulating online shows hooded
figures apparently engaging in a ritual
staged under a huge statue of a hindu
deity at the end of which a woman is
stabbed but the footage appears to have
been recorded as part of a prank by
scientists then you get this on
wikipedia the cern ritual hoax
okay far be it from me to claim it was
anything other than a prank but it
reminds me of uh have you are you guys
watching the boys
i know it i haven't seen it it's the new
show on on amazon prime and i'm not
going to spoil it but there's a point at
which two characters are arguing and
then one character turns out to be
recording so the other character goes
you're not supposed to record when we're
running lines
and i thought that was hilarious because
like that's a way out of getting caught
so someone's filming you like oh we're
just
it was we were acting the whole time
and then i see this and it's like
someone posts video footage showing a
human sacrifice and they're like oh it's
a prank this is a prank bro just art
it's a prank just art we just we're just
doing it we got you buddy we got you and
you know you know but it looks like you
stabbed that woman no she's not
she's screaming
that's acting so so the issue is look
here's what i'm gonna say
i have no evidence of anything about
what happened with that human sacrifice
thing at cern
but i'm not just going to believe the
media when they're like it's a prank bro
i'm like okay well dude i don't know
that doesn't debunk anything you're just
saying it's a prank you know
interference patterns so if there's
multiple frequencies going on that
aren't the same they interfere with each
other and then you get a diminishment um
and if people are vibrating
uh and there's too many of them and
their their vibrations are interfering
with each other that would mean that you
need to remove some of the interference
well i think i think
i'm sorry
i'm talking about producing coherence
you want to talk about conspiracy
theories let's talk about conspiracy
theories what is going on all right
check it out
so uh there's the fluoride conspiracy
theory that calcifies your pineal gland
or whatever i don't know what that means
um
i guess it does i don't know does it do
anything about it the idea is yes it
does i've read scientific data that says
the pineal gland can calcify yeah and so
people often say that that pineal gland
is like the third eye to help you
perceive the spiritual and stuff and by
living in a world where we've
we've neutralized our abilities because
of fluoride we've
essentially destroyed our third eye or
whatever
and so there's that idea then this was a
funny one the double slit experiment
right right you guys know about the
double slit experiment yes you don't let
me explain so uh they if you take a big
sheet of metal
and then you uh behind it you put a big
target board
if you fire off a bunch of shotgun
blasts at that sheet of metal with a
single slit through it
when you go behind it what will you see
on the target board a straight line of
of pellets or you know or buckshot or
whatever from the shotgun so the the
plate shields everything but that slit
if you put two slits what would you
expect to see two straight lines right
behind it
they did this with electrons
through the single slit they got what's
called a uh part a particular a
particulate pad or particle pattern
meaning a straight line of electrons hit
the back sensor
when they used two the double slit they
got an interference pattern suggesting
waves
which is more like water
hippies then went on to be like whoa
that proves that the observer changes
reality and it's like well
no it's like the method by which we
measured it changed wave wave function
collapse so it doesn't mean a whole lot
but a lot of people believe the double
slit experiment proves
that the observer plays a role in when
reality collapses to a single point that
is there could be an infinite number of
universes and that you as an observer
observing something determine when it
collapses to a single position as
opposed to a superposition to
oversimplify it again your observation
manipulates reality and creates it
if that is true then the conspiracy
theory goes there are too many people on
the planet and all of their observations
are interfering with each other creating
a chaotic world which results in a
donald trump presidency
so the conspiracy theory is global
elites want to call as many people as
possible not because of overpopulation
but to diminish the amount of of
observers who are affecting reality
i think it's all magic talk mumbo jumbo
and might as well just be a science
fiction novel but what is happening
through corporate media where they're
giving us a distortion of information
through that it's like every time you
read anything it's i think what's
happening in the double split you got
most of it right but i think there's
something about it was when they had two
slits if they fired the electrons
through and no one was watching they
would come back later and they'd find
two two pattern two lines but if they
record it i could be getting it
backwards no no no no when they find the
interference pattern when the other way
around when they when they measured
which slit the electrons were going
through they got they went through one
or the other right they got they got a
particle pattern when they didn't
measure it they went through what looked
like all of those it went through all
and created a wave pattern so that's
when they were like wow the act of
measuring which one it went through
changed wave function so too much
observation is creating too too stagnant
of a reality
is the conspiracy theory in reality
there's a much simpler explanation
imagine there is an uh so so i'm sorry
for all the hippies out there who
believe in the double-slit experiment
i'm going to debunk it for you uh or not
debunk it but cast doubt because i've
always thought that it would make that
the simpler explanation would be it has
something to do with the function of the
measuring well exactly so yeah
so imagine there is a table and an ant
is walking across the table and you are
like i wonder how far that ant has
walked so you take a ruler and slam it
on the table and then the ant turns left
and you go
the act of observing the ant change the
direction i can control ants with my
mind and you're like no dude you put a
ruler next to it and it got scared and
ran away
whatever you did to monitor the electron
interfered with its function and changed
what was going to happen that's the
simple answer right a lot of the hippy
dippy people are like it means like when
you look at it with your own eyes it
changes it does indicate that the
observation tool can interfere with
behavior and wondering we are
observation tools are we inadvertently
interfering with reality just by
watching it is that why meditation is so
valuable because you you remove yourself
from the observer but that is not the
point i'm making the point i'm making is
that when you slam a ruler next to an
ant you create a physical disturbance
and the ant will change its behavior i
think the physical disturbance of the
observer is undetectable it is it is not
the fact that a human eyeball is looking
at a machine measuring an electron it's
that you are injecting something to the
point where the electron is causing it
to physically interact i bet when you're
when you're thinking about something
you're doing that too
i don't i don't believe it's i don't
think that that but you know far be it
for me i don't know but this is why
let's talk about meditation like i mean
twitter i don't know if you guys feel it
but i get agitated when i get on there
so not always sometimes i'm so educated
i don't realize
well i mean that's everyone
have
opens
twitter
meditated for like 20 minutes and come
out like a placid lake
well it's nice to just get all the noise
out for sure i mean you have to do it
and is it like if we don't meditate
they're gonna they're coming for you
they're coming for you
what i'm doing is meditating but i'm
trying to stay away from the phone and
turn off the tvs well i don't own a tv
so what is it it's either either they're
going to try and reduce the population
by making us have less kids or we're all
going to start meditating and everyone's
going to change we're all going to go to
the metaverse
so think about this if the observation
thing and the meditations thing is real
that means prayer is real
prayer is for sure real and that means
the more people who believe in this and
pray towards it and focus on it the more
real it be prayer seems to have a
function it's like dropping a pebble in
a lake if you pray once and you think
healthy you pray that and then the
pebble drops then you have no thought
and the ripples will go out and things
will become healthy but if you keep
thinking healthy healthy healthy it's
like dropping a lot of pebbles and
increase interference and you don't get
the effect that you intend didn't they
do a study that found that people who
were prayed for often recovered better
or something like that yep yeah i was
reading i was reading i was i was
actually i was reading some scientific
study a while ago i could be wrong
though but it sounds like you read it i
i don't know the details on me right now
but you know just just
stories like that
and studies like that and then and just
just seeing the power of it in my life
seeing the power of it in
in my career politics
um you know
i i undoubtedly right and with
unreservedly believe in the power of
prayer um and i've and i've been
teaching it to my children as just part
we make it part of our daily life you
know we do it before we eat we do it
before we go to bed um we sit we pray
the rosary right that's that's what we
do right
and it's not something where i'm like
you know screaming at them you know you
got that word wrong or something like
you just make it you make it part of
life yeah and it works in the opposite
direction too for doom like in the town
that i've been writing about for the
next book
although it's very religious there's a
lot of people who've they're deeply
connected right to the civil war and the
doom has never left this town and like
this yes it's just one thing after
another it's almost like they're
manifesting it i don't think they are
but it's you know they're they're
praying and there's people there who are
deeply religious but the the younger
generation right now is so filled with
doom i mean it's they're completely
hopeless and like they're it's like the
town is inescapable it seems like a
metaphor for the country at large
perhaps for
that age group to be scary if you if you
if you search on the internet you can
find sources telling you anything you
want to hear that's pretty true that's
the real challenge that's fine
absolutely i found studies saying it
does help and i found somebody saying it
doesn't help have you guys heard of dr
masaru emoto he did a study of human
consciousness on water he'd focus prayer
on water and then measure the molecular
structure of the water and you'd see
different patterns depending on the
energy he's putting into it they'd be
like no scientific method prove it do it
a million times and then show that but
he'd get different responses when he
would do it so it's impossible to prove
with the scientific ethics i think it
disproves it the science
it disproves as per the scientific
method but that's not the only form of
science it's just one of the best ones
we have right now if he can't recreate
the molecular structure through thought
then he's not doing anything according
to scientific method he's not but just
because but it does seem to be happening
he just can't
but explain it necessarily it doesn't
seem to be happening
if if you if you so it's so cool so this
is a guy he like took water
and then he like prayed on it and he
would focus on a word like anger or pain
and then he would take a look at the
molecular structures and find patterns
emerging but he couldn't recreate any of
the patterns so it's just random noise
for all we know it's just the water hit
other water and then shuffled into a
pattern then he prayed and went i must
have done that it's like well you
couldn't recreate it so you clearly
didn't yeah it's not recreated that's
the thing about the scientific method
though is it's like recreate it or get
out and sometimes things aren't
recreatable they just happen you know
they call them miracles sometimes in in
the religious sense or um but i think
the scientific method we created it as
it's it's a it's a newer form of science
but it doesn't mean it's gonna be the
final form of science i think eventually
we'll figure out there's more to what's
going on than the hard
matter that we that we perceive
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you